elon musk is the billionaire ceo of
spacex and tesla and was ranked by
forbes as number five on their list of
the world's most powerful people he went
from being raised by his abusive father
in the suburbs of south africa to now
being one of the richest people in the
world with a net worth of 98.5
billion dollars
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
nation top 10.
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best elon musk and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one learn on your own
first of all you don't need college
learning learn stuff
okay everything is available basically
for free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
there is a value that colleges have
which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's is
can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of sort of annoying
homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
get it done
you know that's that's like the main
value of college and then also you know
if you you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning
rule number two innovate fast enough the
real way i think you you actually
achieve
intellectual property protection is by
innovating
fast enough if your rate of innovation
is high
then you don't need to worry about
protecting vip
because other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
and i do i do say this to my teams like
uh
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go
innovation per year if you're what i say
like is is what matters not
innovation absent time because
if you wanted to take say 100
improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different so
it's like what is your rate of
innovation that that matters and is the
rate of innovation
um is that accelerating or decelerating
um and a weird thing happens when
companies get big is that
most companies or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
is not there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation
the incentive structure must be aligned
with that
that's fundamental rule number three
work super hard
you need to work if you depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company uh
in instead of getting an apartment we
just rented us a small office
and we slept on the couch and we we
showered at the the ymca
and uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so
the the website was up during the day
and i was coding at night seven days a
week all the time
um and i i sort of briefly had a
girlfriend that period and in order to
be with me she'll have to sleep in the
office so
i work hard like
i mean every waking hour that's that's
the the thing i would i would say
if you're particularly if you're
starting a company
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working 50
hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as
the other company rule number four
believe
i can conclusion that my initial premise
was was wrong
uh that in fact the um
there's there's a great deal of will uh
you know
that there's there's not such a shortage
um
but people don't think there's a way um
and and that if people thought there was
there was a way or do something that
wouldn't
you know break the federal budget um
then
then people would support it um which in
retrospect i think is actually
kind of obvious because um the
the united states is a distillation of
the human spirit of exploration
people came here from other places um i
mean it's
you know there's no nation there's no i
mean there's no nation that that's more
a nation of explorers than united united
states but
but people need to believe that it's
possible and it's that it's not
you know it's they're not going to give
up like healthcare or something
important
you know it's it's got to be that that
that's important so so i thought okay
well
then it's not a question of well it's a
question of showing that there's a way
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear if you
have a great product lots of people will
buy it
and then the company will be successful
that ended up being worse than if we
designed a car from from the beginning
rule number five filter feedback well in
the beginning nobody wanted a tesla
i can tell you that
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to the sports car
uh people like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline car works fine
i'm like no electric car is better i
should try it
and it was hard to get people to
do a test drive nobody knew who we were
and then we heard this company and like
yeah we're named after nikola tesla you
know that guy nope
um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying yeah i really
want an electric car
i heard that zero times um
somebody like it's like man we're gonna
make an electric car and show that these
things can be good
um and then people will want them um
you know it's like it was like henry
ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say
a faster horse so if you did like a big
survey and say hey what hey
public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food
and uh you know be stronger
and live longer and that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse um
because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's not that sounds crazy um but
when you actually make an automobile and
give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
[Laughter]
yeah so carry
more more weight than a horse and go
further and that kind of thing
so anyway it's like
when when it's a radically new product
people don't know that they want it
because
it's just not in their in their scope i
think
when they first started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey i think
this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey
will you ever buy a tv now i was like 96
percent of respondents said no
some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about so the big game changing
stuff at the beginning
is a company push kind of a thing most
of the time
but then changes to the product over
time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah change changes to the product over
time can be
incremental changes um then
the customers can certainly tell you
it's good to get customer feedback to
say
how can we improve the product um
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over time customer
feedback after they
they have the fundamental thing is
is great rule number six become
comfortable with failing
i think failure is bad um i don't think
it's good um
but if if if something's important
enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome
is is that it's not going to work and
they should reconcile themselves to that
plus strong possibility and they should
only do it if they feel that they're
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know
um because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's
the very beginning it's kind of fun and
then
it's really hellish for a number of
years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully uh um
he said yeah
you're starting companies like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
um and you agree with that
generally true um yeah
and and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not going to be successful
rule number seven do something
exceptional
we have a lot of good good people at
spacex that
um a lot of really talented people
uh in fact i wonder like sometimes
how we can make use of their talents in
the best way
because you know i think we're often not
using their talents in the best way
yeah but you know to the point of the
question i was just asked i want to make
sure
tesla recruiting does not have anything
that says requires
university because that's absurd
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability i don't
consider going to college
evidence of exceptional ability in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know when you look
at like you know
gates is a pretty smart guy he dropped
out
john was pretty smart he dropped out you
know larry ellison
smart guy he dropped out like obviously
not needed
so did shakespeare even go to college
probably not
rule number eight maximize the useful
output
i think of the these things is just
there's a certain amount of time
and within that time you want the
the best net outcome so for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do there's
going to be uh some of which will fail
some which will succeed
and you want the the the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
um so
um we have to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch
until you get a real easy one they
didn't give you
three shots and the third one they say
okay and they
get off the they go back to the put
somebody else up there
um so these your three strikes on on the
baseball
um you know not
only bad anymore so so what you're
what you're really looking for is like
what's the batting average
you know how you doing on uh
on score um and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output um
that useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic
rule number nine don't just follow the
trends don't just follow the trend
so um you may have heard me say
that it's good to think in terms of the
physics approach of first principles
which is rather than reasoning by
analogy
you boil things down to the most
fundamental truths you can imagine and
you
reason up from there and this is a good
way to
figure out if if something really
makes sense or if it's just what
everybody else is doing
it it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything
it takes a lot of effort but if you're
trying to do something new
it's the best way to think and that
framework was developed
by by physicists to figure out
counterintuitive things
um like quantum mechanics so it's
really a powerful powerful method and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have a healthy skepticism i believe
in the scientific method and one should
be
one should have a healthy skepticism of
things in general and
you know as if first things from a
scientific standpoint you always look at
things probabilistically not
definitively
and so i think a lot of times if
somebody's a skeptic in the science
community what they're really saying is
that they're not sure that it's 100
certain
that that this is the case but that's
that's that's not the point the point is
um that is is is look at it from the
other side see
what do you think the percentage chance
is of this
being catastrophic for some meaningful
percentage of those population
um is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
if you're creating a company or if
you're joining a company
the most important thing is to attract
is to
attract great people so either be with
join a group that's amazing that you
really respect or if you're building a
company you've got to gather great
people i mean all the company is
is a group of people that have gathered
together to create a product or service
and so depending upon how talented and
hard-working that group is
and degree to which they are focused
cohesively
in a good direction that will determine
the success of the company
so do everything you can to to gather
great people
if if you're creating a company
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there